[Music]
[Applause]
all right Harvard maybe the oldest
university in America but it's also the
absolute worst school for freedom of
speech according to the foundation for
individual rights and expression Harvard
now unseated last year's Champion
Colombia and scored a negative 11 out of
a hundred on a free speech index things
are so bad at Harvard that nine
professors were reported for things they
said or wrote and seven of them were
professionally disciplined of course
Harvard is not bringing its best and
brightest school's newest Professor is
none other than former Chicago mayor
Lori lightweight
she gets to join the ranks of Humpty
Dumpty from fake news CNN here now with
reaction former Arkansas Governor Mike
Huckabee Governor great to have you
all right governor
Lori lightweight and Humpty Dumpty is
that the best that Harvard has to offer
well it sure seems to be you know
Harvard was started in 1636 as a college
for ministers to preach the gospel think
about how far they've drifted from their
roots and now having Lori Lightfoot a
person under whom crime went up 30
percent while she was mayor of Chicago
that's like asking Jeffrey Dahmer to
come teach a class on culinary skills I
mean it couldn't get any worse than
having her come and talk about how to
lead a city and how to deal with issues
like crime and health you know it's very
interesting because it used to be like
oh you want your kids to go to an Ivy
League school last place I'd want my
kids to go to school now is an Ivy
League school I mean they're so woke
it's getting so bad there's no free open
exchange of ideas ideals and opinions
what has happened over the time
well over time a lot of these colleges
have decided that they just want to be
so far to the left they're appealing to
the least educated or let me put it this
way maybe most educated but the least
intelligent people you know give me a
couple of rednecks in a pickup truck any
day over a whole Bus full of Harvard
professors who don't let students think
for themselves and want to not uh simply
help them to understand how to think but
indoctrinate them into what to think
that's not the purpose of a university
it's to give students the ability to
think for themselves and even to be
controversial and to challenge their
thoughts that's not happening at Harvard
people are wasting their money in a big
way when they send their students there
now you know I'll take a kid that went
to a state school whose parents were
civil servants like my parents were and
uh any day Governor thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else